how do you balance the idea of checking
the ego well in an interview scenario
where you need to talk about yourself
okay so good good question I I would say
in that situation and that's something
that it's not just an interview
situation or you're going to need to do
that I mean you're given with your your
superiors you know throughout the course
of your career whatever that may be
you're constantly interacting with
people and you've got you're going to
want to make an impression so I think
one of the best ways to do this is
instead of you speaking about why you're
so awesome just state facts of let's say
accomplishments and let them speak for
themselves in other words you know you
wouldn't want to say you know I am the
best project manager in the entire world
mmm right that's not that sounds ego
centric you know instead you'd say uh
you know I got this a we had a 38
million dollar project got it done on
time under budget ahead of schedule and
when I got done with that when they
moved me to another project that was off
track and we got that one back on
schedule and back on track as well so
that that's the kind of experience that
I've had and I had loved to bring out
here to this company right so you're not
you're not you know there's a hint of
hey this is what I did I can get some
stuff done but you're not saying listen
I'm better than the people you currently
have so you should hire me because I'm
the best but you don't want to do that
and you know so so yeah just build think
about it you know before you go in how
what what experience that you have
represents the good qualities that you
have so then you can say if they say you
know how are you at meeting timelines
you don't say I am perfect or whatever
late I'm don't you just say you say you
say well you know as far as meeting
timelines here's a bunch of projects
that I got completed on time the only
one that I missed was one that we had to
rollback because whatever that we are
actually showing a little bit more
humility you're saying hey here's what
happened you're being logical about it
and you know speaking of that I actually
got a good question that's sim
or this one about what's the best way to
interview people to see if they can be
in a leadership position and this is
really hard this is really hard because
it's really hard to interviews and
working I work with all kinds of
different companies and everybody always
says you know hey what's the best way to
interview and man I interviewed this guy
and he seems so great or I interview
this woman and she seemed incredible and
her her paper looked great you know she
looked great on paper and we hired her
and she's a disaster or he's a disaster
or whatever the case may be because
because there's people that are very
good interviewers right I mean there's
people that can interview well they have
the gift of gab they can they can be
asked their way through anything and
make themselves sound good so it can be
really hard to identify someone's good
it is actually going to be fit for a
leadership position or really any
position so one of the things that that
I always tell people to do is when you
go into these when you want to ask
interview questions ask them
scenario-based questions and say okay
here's what's going on you got these
three people in your department and one
of the people has come to you and said
that they think there might be something
illegal going on and with the other two
what actions do you take and you know
have a scenario built out that you can
actually talk through and see where they
go and see what their mindset is and see
what they're going to develop as a plan
and see how they would actually plan so
it's a great way of figuring out how
people think and then you know even
that's not a guarantee because there's
people that can can navigate those types
of answers as well so you know one thing
you can do is hire people on a little
bit of a trial basis and that can be
difficult in some situations where
people are walking away from one job
into another job I'm not going to do it
on the 90-day trial basis but when you
do have that opportunity it's a good
thing to do as well um but hey so going
back to the first question about keeping
your ego in check in an interview like I
said be confident but not cocky and let
the facts of your experience speak for
your your abilities rather than beating
your own chest yeah so it's almost like
I mean correct me if I'm wrong here so
you you essentially even if you're
talking
sup you just used simply state the fact
that's it you just state the fact don't
say your opinion about it no like
because you're sayin briefs say the
facts yeah here's what I did you know
right we turned this project around we
got it on chip on track and on budget
and the despot type of that's the type
of experience that I have in those
situations right just like how you're
saying even if someone had got like an
award to be the best
whatever favorite of the year the right
filter you're the best whatever of the
year and then um like to say that in a
factual way would be I was recognized as
the best guy in or instead of saying I'm
the best guy in the world to my award to
prove it you know so it's like you're
seeing the fact that you were recognized
you know not so much the fact there was
a very good way of doing it stick to the
facts right just the fastest effects